imagine you are the ceo of a company
that produces two models of cars a model
s that requires two days to be made four
by three units and has a profit margin
of 1k and a model y that requires 15
days to be made eight battery units and
has a profit margin of 5k
if you are given one year and a stock of
500 battery units how would you go about
maximizing this company's profits your
decision variables are s the number of
cars of model s and y the number of cars
of model y and the amount of tax evasion
that
this function that you want to maximize
is called the objective and these
inequalities that our decision variables
should satisfy are called constraints
both the objective and constraints are
linear functions for this reason
problems like these are called lps or
linear programs in general a linear
program could have more than just two
variables and more than just two
constraints
the set of all the decisions that
satisfy the constraints is called the
feasible set and you would recognize a
linear program immediately by the fact
that faces of this feasible set are flat
and the technical term for a set with
flat faces is polyhedra linear programs
were one of the biggest achievements of
the 20th century they have been
successfully applied to a wide set of
problems such as production planning
scheduling agriculture and
transportation moreover ideas from
linear programming like the importance
of convexity
duality
and interior point methods were found to
be crucial in the development of more
general classes of nonlinear problems
there are two practical ways to find the
optimal solution to a linear program the
simplex method that travels from one
vertex to a neighboring vertex along
edges until the optimal solution is
found and the interior point method that
as the name indicates goes directly
through the interior of the feasible set
towards the optimal solution to solve
the linear program in python install the
package cbx pi
import it describe your problem
and call the solve method to get the
optimal solution
i will end this video with two major
simple to state open questions related
to linear programs first the hirsch
conjecture for a polyhedron in dimension
n defined by m constraints and for two
arbitrary vertices v and w
can we bound the number of steps it
takes to go from v to w with a
polynomial in n at m
the second related major open problem is
as follows is there an algorithm for
solving linear programs that runs in
strongly polynomial time maybe a variant
of the simplex method or the interior
point method has a strongly pulled on
your running time but today we just like
the know-how to either prove or disprove
that
this was linear programming in two
minutes if you want to see more videos
like this one make sure to like and
subscribe and see you next time
i